a group of students prepare a large
batch of conductive dough a soft
substance that can conduct electricity
and then mold the dough into several
cylinders with various cross-sectional
areas a and lengths L each student
applies a potential difference Delta V
across the ends of a dough cylinder and
determines the resistance of the
cylinder the results of their
experiments are shown in the table below
so what they're doing they're taking
this material this conductive dough and
they're making cylinders of different
cross-sectional areas and different
lengths so they're varying the area the
cross-sectional area and the length but
it's all being made out of this can the
same material and then depending on how
they vary that you get different
resistances the students want to
determine the resistivity of the dough
cylinders so just as a reminder
resistivity is different than resistance
a particular shape of a given material
will have us and length and cross
sectional area all of that will have a
given resistance but a resistivity is a
property of the material and the
relationship between resistance and
resistivity you can write it as
resistance is equal to resistivity which
is usually represented with the Greek
letter Rho times the length of the thing
that you're measuring the resistance of
divided by the cross-sectional area and
so if you have a higher resistivity all
else equal that would make a higher
resistance but if you have a higher
length that also makes a higher
resistance but if you have a higher
cross-sectional area then that lowers
the resistance and if you were to solve
for Rho you could write rho is equal to
resistance times cross sectional area
over l so then says indicate below which
quantities could be graphed to determine
a value for the resistivity of the dough
cylinders you may use the remaining
columns in the table above as needed to
record any quantities including units
that are not already in the
Abell so pause this video and think
about how you would do that well I can
think of two ways to do that you could
make a plot you could make a scatter
plot or where on the horizontal axis you
put L over a and on the vertical axis
you put resistance and then the
resistivity would be the slope of a line
that you try to fit to those points so
that's one way to do it another way to
do it is you could make your horizontal
axis your a over L and then you can make
your vertical axis your row and then you
could try to fit a horizontal line to
those points because your resistivity
should not be dependent on a / L I'm
actually going to pick this second
option because if I'm doing this
primarily by hand it's at least to me
easier to fit a horizontal line than to
fit a a non horizontal line as I would
have to do there so let's do that so my
vertical axis I'm going to do
resistivity resistivity so that's is
this tivity and it's going to be in ohm
meters and then in my horizontal axis I
am going to do my area divided by length
and that's going to be in meters and now
to be able to do this I need to
calculate these things so I want to
calculate my area divided by length and
I also want to calculate my resistivity
Rho and so area divided by length Oh
point zero zero zero four nine divided
by point zero three is equal to zero
point zero one six so we have zero point
zero one six two significant digits here
two significant digits and the things
that I'm dividing with and then I can
calculate row by multiplying my area
divided by length times resistance times
my resistance that I measured twenty
three point six it's important to
realize that when you do things
experiment
things aren't going to be perfect
there's a lot of noise in the real world
so I'll round that to I'll round that to
since I have two significant digits here
two significant digits here so 0.39 so
this is zero point three nine and then
I'll keep doing that calculation and for
the sake of time I will just speed up
the video now
all right and now we can move to this
second part now it says on the grid
below plot the appropriate quantities to
determine the resistivity of the DOE
cylinders clearly scale and label all
axes including units as appropriate so
as we mentioned on our horizontal axis
right over here we want to put our cross
sectional area divided by the length of
our resistors and so that's going to be
we have meter squared divided by meters
so that's going to be in meters and then
in our vertical axis we want to plot our
resistivity for our resistivity ro and
that's going to be in ohm meters and now
we need to think about the scales and so
the scale of this vertical axis if we go
back over here we see that all of our
calculations for a row well it's between
around 3/10 4/10 like that or you could
say between 30 hundredths and I guess we
got up to 41 hundredths so we could have
a reasonable scale here we have 1 2 3 4
5 so we could say this is 10 hundredths
which is the same thing as 1/10 this is
20 hundredths this is 30 hundredths and
this is 40 hundredths for our row scale
and then for our area divided by length
we have so let's see if we view all of
this in terms of ten thousandths we go
between thirty-eight ten thousandths all
the way to 160 ten thousandths
so let's make this fifty ten thousands
zero point zero zero five zero this
would be 110 thousandths zero point zero
one zero zero this would be 150 ten
thousand zero point zero one five zero
and this would be two hundred ten
thousands zero point zero two zero at
zero and this would be 250 ten thousands
all right I think I have my scales right
so now we just plot our points so let's
see the first one has a resistivity of
0.1 0.3 nine and are a divided by L is
which is this is going to be in meters
this is going to be one hundred sixty
ten thousandth of a meter and so we
would go look up 160 right over here so
this is 150 and then we would want to go
one fifth of the way between this and
this and it's neatly divided into five
sections here so this would be 160 and
then I would want 0.39 ohm meters for
the resistivity so that would put us
right over there so that's my first data
point and now if I go to my second 198
10,000th zero point three one
so 98 ten thousandths will be right
around here and then at zero point three
one would be right around there so
that's my second data point and then I
get 266 ten thousands and 0.41 so
sixty-six ten thousandths would get us
let's see this would be sixty sixty six
ten thousandths and then we have zero
point four one so that puts us right
over there someplace like that and then
last but not least 38 ten thousandths
and zero point four so then we have 38
10,000 so this would be 40 this would be
30 so 38 is like here and then we go to
forty hundreds so it is like that so
those are our four data points and then
they say use the above graph to estimate
a value for the resistivity of the dough
cylinders well as we said the
resistivity should be constant it
shouldn't depend on our area divided by
our length and so if we want to fit a
horizontal line to this they gets as
close as possible ideally we would have
a computer but we're going to hand to do
it we have three of these points that
are pretty close to 40 hundredths but
then we have this one down here so I'd
want to get a little bit closer to these
three up there because there's so many
data points there so I would say a line
that looks something something like that
and so this point right over here this
is maybe approximately zero point three
seven so this is zero point three seven
Oh meters I would say zero point three
seven ohm meters and we're done and
frankly another way to think about this
is you could have done it potentially
even without the graph by saying well
look a good estimate for my resistivity
of my conductive dough is to just take
the mean of these values but they wanted
us to use the graph and so one technique
would be alright let's try to fit a
horizontal line the other technique with
a graph would have been plotting L over
a here and then plotting resistance on
our vertical axis and then our estimate
of the slope of the fitted line that
would be our estimate of Rho but that
would have been frankly harder to do
than even what we did here